now Incredibles 2 is the movie that I
have been waiting for since long before
there was d23 since hi I saw the first
set of story reels I said I can't wait
for the sequel so we finally have it in
the works
ladies and gentlemen I'd like to please
welcome the writer director of The
Incredibles - mr. Brad Bird
[Applause]
[Music]
and ladies and gentlemen the voice of
Edna mode ladies Elvis I I don't appear
without getting the check darling but
the Edna it's in the mail the checks in
the mail
you know we agreed that I would be paid
I understand that but we're not none of
us are being paid for this you know
so maybe come on out and talk to d23
they really want to see you
very well I will appear in the form of a
disillusioned middle-aged man a boy
dependable Bradburn what separates the
Incredibles from other superhero films
is that it's fundamentally a story about
family they just happen to have
superpowers with this new film we're
excited to jump back into that world we
have a wonderful cast returning from the
first film playing Bob mr. Craig T
Nelson
[Applause]
[Music]
Holly Hunter
[Applause]
Sarah Vowell Chuck Milner
the legendary samuel l.jackson
[Music]
yes ladies and gentlemen the cast of
incredible two
[Applause]